Cigarettes and marijuana have been used for centuries, but the process of steaming
Materials have become common only recently. So, what science says about these
Technology? Is it better for your health really?
When smoking normally, the heat of the torch will cause the material to be converted from solid state
To the gaseous state (vapor). This causes nicotine to be released from the cigarette and then absorbed through the lungs
Blood, causing an increase in heart rate, narrowing of the blood vessels, and the release of dopamine in the blood
Brain and sense of alertness. But the fact that nicotine is a stimulant is not available
Causing "nostalgia", which eventually leads to addiction to many. in a
In the case of marijuana, THC's effective content turns into vapor and follows the same pathway
Until it reaches the blood, but it causes different effects explained in the video "your brain
Under the influence of marijuana "here.
Smoking takes only 6 seconds until effective contents reach your nervous system, unlike
Chewing tobacco or eating marijuana in a meal that takes much longer, but you
Smoke inhalation in the process. This smoke contains partially the particles
Tar in your body, has a cancerous effect, causes blackness in the teeth and breaks taste buds. Here
The role of "fumigation".
If the active content is heated enough to convert it into vapor without having to burn it
You can theoretically get a quick effect without leading to
Damage caused by smoke inhalation. A fumigant usually contains a glass or metal chamber that passes through it
Electronic current - This way it can be heated to a certain temperature
With less burning possible, which means you breathe in much less smoke.
For marijuana users, fumigants have become common since plant material can be heated to
A certain temperature - usually between 185 and 210 degrees Celsius - is erased
For steam containing THC. In electronic cigarettes, liquid solutions are used instead
Of tobacco is usually dried; this solution contains water, nicotine, alkaline
And evaporates at much lower temperatures. But here
Things get a bit complicated.
The solution contains a substance similar to that used in cosmetics and food and is used
To maintain moisture without causing the contents to wear. One of the most commonly used substances is propylene glycol, which is
Used in theatrical smoke, known to cause irritation in the eyes and infections
Pneumonia. So what can happen after using electronic cigarettes for a long time? Still
Scientists are studying these effects. Although the US Food and Drug Administration has agreed to
These cigarettes, there is still much to know.
The solution varies greatly between manufacturers without any controls for almost additives.
Some were found to contain diacetyl, a chemical used in butter to give
Taste "butter". Inhalation of this substance may cause a tear in the lungs known
With "popcorn lung", the name that was called after hundreds of workers in the popcorn factory when inhaled
Of this substance and their irreversible lung damage. This is an example of what can be
Lack of quality control in electronic cigarettes can be a cause for great concern.
But current evidence suggests that fumigants supply the body with nicotine with side effects
Much less due to reduced carcinogens and inhalation of smoke. But being less dangerous
Does not mean it is safe. Electronically flavored cigarettes (such as berries or grapes) are found to contain
On other harmful chemicals. Passive smoking is still a problem;
Of fumigants known as "nanoparticles" have an effect on lung health. as such
There are fears that these electronic cigarettes are considered less harmful to the point that they have become
More attractive to the young class. A study reported that the continuous use of electronic cigarettes for adolescents
In the sixth to twelfth grades increased from 6% to 20% within 3 years.
In contrast, many of the negative effects of normal smoking
Comes from long-term studies, for example, cancers are very late. As vaporizers
Relatively recent, we simply do not have the capacity to conduct long-term studies. So
We have to wait for what the future holds for us.
Thank you so much for the audible support of this episode and to give you a free audio book on
aubile.com/asap Recommend this week to Elon Musk: Tesla, SpaceX and the
Quest for a Fantastic Future by Ashley Vance, which reveals the whole scene
About the life of the genius Tesla and his work and his vision. You can get a free copy at audible.com/asap
Or any book of your choice within a huge collection provided by the site! We love ebooks because they are fantastic
During movement and transition.
Do not forget to ask us your fire questions and subscribe to weekly science videos.
:)